so for the class
classes this week next week's whatever
we have which event julian coming
well championship and other than taking
some book and saying okay this is a good
night bad bishop nice look and all those
whatever ideas that some people speak
about
we will look at tiny bit games of anand
and
to see
tiny bit games of ananda and carlson
they are going to start playing
two days right like i think saturday
morning is the first round for
3 30 here 4 30 eastern time so we are i
don't know if i'm not mistaken 60 hours
away from the first game something like
that less
50 something hours okay so let's see we
will see several of the games now one
one thing is has to be said very very
clearly
there's a very big anand carlson
difference from their 2008 even 9 and 10
games
where in 2008 it's clear that anand was
still a better player
i think in
2009
they were quite about same level maybe
like
but already in 2010 it was clear that
carlson is is already stronger i think
someone said that the score is
six wins and three losses for anand
and i'm not certain if the all six wins
are in full time control we can actually
look at that in a minute but
the three losses are the last ones like
another the last 11 i think eleven games
are like eight dwarfs and three wins for
carlton and the wins have become like
actually some of them were quite
embarrassing for
for anon so
a very big difference between past games
and
games right now this is actually one
amazing game that
a nun won in leonardo's 2018.
okay nothing
really surprising about anand playing
this love defense
we won some great games actually
most famous game that he recently won in
this opening was against
one of the best games in long long time
but all preparation
was against arunian
i think
yeah i think in vacancy it was he
sacrificed everything and checkmate and
it was just preparation that he had for
the match with the girlfriend
okay so this is an opening that
anand first played well not first but he
had some big gains playing it
against karpov
in a match when carlsen was
six months old i would say
all right so
somewhere in the middle of 91 an
unplayed matches with karpov actually a
match that he lost
but he clearly should have won that
match already
and cup of
pretty much throughout his career we
never went into botswini variation or
moscow
carpool always played e3
and then queen c2 so many big games in
that match
were this way
but okay
and interesting part is that anand
never went into the botvinnik variation
it's amazing like
the
big line that okay kramnik and shiro
were the most
notable players to have played it the
best games in this line belongs to
pretty much to them i mean some two of
the top dutch players
luke van valley and juan piquette
were also
the biggest expert in the world this is
summer in the
90s bit after it
but
anand always always played the moscow
variation h6 now what is the difference
let's just tiny for a second just speak
about this line
if e4
b5 defending the pawn
e5
h6 has to break the pin
has to break the pin
white sacrifice
and okay
and then we are in the
main botswinic line either take
or g3 and
most complicated lines in chess are
there
but if black plays first h6
if white retreats to h4 which is one of
the main lines the other one is of
course to take the knight
then instead of b5 right now that will
transpose to botvanic variation after e5
black can first attack the bishop
and then play b5
and okay many many great games and
unplayed
in this line including
one huge victory
in mexico city in the world championship
that he won the tournament in 2007 if
i'm not mistaken
in the first round
i think the first one or maybe the
second hebitaronyan which black with
huge novelty so this hernandez has been
playing forever actually carlson has
been
having some games with bishop g5 with
white i mean will be interesting this is
definitely a line that
we might see in the
championship although somehow i have a
feeling that carlsen will deviate from
theory big time but
just my
so indeed we are
heading to this line
all right carson has been playing bishop
g5 he had some games the other line let
me just show it quickly is to take
and play e3
some other moves gotham actually wants
some
nice positional games with white well
the idea
white gave
the bishop
right so black has a pair of bishop but
the bishop on c8 is not that pretty and
this actually structure resembles a lot
queen's gambit decline
very very similar to
queen's gambit decline structure
but okay bishop h4 is of course more
aggressive
exactly the purpose of why playing h6
before
knight e5 now many other
possibilities
h5
okay
so of course the idea to trap the bishop
h4 is a i believe one of the
probably the main line in this position
carlson played f3
h4
okay there are many many positions that
are like this
coming from the slav defense coming from
even some flank openings basically white
gives away the c4 pawn
black is protecting it with b5 like he
did c6 but what is the price that black
is playing here
no in this specific position actually
also the
king side is weak so you're right but in
many position even when the king side is
okay
he has a little bit problem white has a
very strong center
this bishop is blocked and potentially
at some point we will see a4 putting
pressure against this spawn chain
many in many other versions actually we
see it with
white bishop of the uncharted so many
many games like that
at least the idea of giving the pawn
getting the center
but i think that those types of
positions are very
very okay for an end in general
i mean
he needs inactive play again we will see
which annan comes to the match if it is
a nun that played the tournaments in
2012
it's gonna be ugly match if it is a nun
that played some great matches into a
great match against kramnik in 2008
well it will be
can be very interesting match everyone
knows that carson is a favorite but
well
we'll see which announce comes
knight bd7 capture
and interesting that
capture with the knight
what is black's idea in this position if
black can play several moves what would
what should he play
if i give you to
play three moves with black other than
capturing pieces right you you tell two
kids okay you can play three moves they
tell you okay play here here and take
other other than capturing
with what
e5 or c5 right
exactly
exactly so for that you're going to need
the
controlling e5 and c5
exactly exactly that point
exactly plus i think i think if the
queen take
something like this might be at least a
possibility indeed some of the center
was given away but
just those dark squares are really
kind of bothering
okay knight equals played
castle yeah even here they are
mentioning
this move
and immediately breaking the center has
to play that way
and if take check
this this is type of play that anand can
have really big shot in
playing against carson if the game will
be super boring and long
i think i think definitely
less chances for anon that's why i think
that carlson will just just the feeling
we might see in the match knight f3 g3
first move okay i mean knight f3 g3
bishop g2 just ready opening and just
playing
where carlson is right
okay
with a lot of play for black i mean
obviously this move will create
this weakness may be taken then
this pawn will be hanging
okay castle is logical
e5
okay immediately playing in the center
right we we mentioned that the idea of
knight take you mentioned the pawn break
has to play that
a4 everything is so typical
so now is there anything more logical
than a6
a6 seems pretty logical i i don't know
what to play actually
a6 okay just logical
d5
also logical
i mean what does he want to do
he doesn't want to allow black knight
all day again in the squares
open this diagonal d square
with d5
this bishop is being open and
potentially this square
try and trade off uh
6 was played okay
bishop here is your idea
which is an interesting idea
yes
but now
it's the moment that
i shut up and let you think
and tell me what to play
take on c6
okay let's say that i will play bishop
take
okay that
that's very very good way of thinking we
have to start by looking at the forcing
move we have to right i mean you hear me
already a little bit and we have to
start by forcing move
so let's see
take on c5 only question is whether we
should first take on c6 or first take on
c5
that's a big we will see that in a
second
let's start with this take
take
take
okay black has two possibilities
black intake on
black intake on d1 or black can take on
c6 right
okay
let's see
let's start with queen take screen
that's easy how are we going to take
and black will take on c6
this is just really bad for black right
we will take
take
and take
and this pawn is also gone and with so
many weaknesses probably just lost i
mean it's not better it's just lost okay
so this is clear
gone put put this line behind us
so then take on
c6
okay
what now
if we take
it's tiny less clear right
this position is tiny less clear
so let's take on
b5
pawn take
take if the bishop takes
yes so the queen will take
26
and 97.
but somehow i do not believe in black's
position here at all
something like rook d1
looks very difficult to play for black
this is just one one idea
looks very very very difficult for black
to play but
yeah queen b7
the question where are you heading
i'm not certain but
on the other hand i need to prove
something for the pawn
yeah i was also thinking by the way this
idea
so let's go back you know for example if
i was thinking in a game i understand
this position i think white has pressure
here but
not so easy by the way you know which
move i would play i'll play this move
and this one
i need to i need to attack this one
because if this one falls then this one
falls
that's
yeah it doesn't matter i mean even if
you take this way
i mean i i just need squares for my
bishop
yeah i mean if not e5 is falling it's
game over
i mean it looks i mean looks very bad if
i will take this one
okay so now we will just
just just to see that we haven't
embarrassed ourselves too much here
let's see what computers say
yeah rook j8 was the move that i said i
thought
i i want to play rook g8 g6 computers
say tiny better for what if queen b7 it
doesn't like ah
you see computer also tiny smart it's
starting to like f4
but you know that we have to be stuck
here until he choose f4 to be his
favorite move
even oh it's freight so i didn't even
see freaks
cheers
no i think that's what what there is
there
oh that's it f4 is best move i'm
taking it and running away but okay but
that's that's that's a very typical idea
all right good fritz is genius best ever
forget about houdini
all right
but this is one alternative other
alternative would be maybe maybe to take
first on
to take first on on c6
but either way we understand the idea
they're going to be a series of captures
white queen will invade d6
not so cool for black maybe
so
that's why i not played this move
oh you know some serious dude
i mean defending
exactly what we have seen that is so
weak before
no those positions anand is
you know very very strong i mean if
people remember his games in the match
against kamnik
he just plays like computer
beautiful exactly the line that we have
seen only that this square is covered
exactly
okay
quincy one he wants to take a pawn
that's not bad
defending the pawn
rook d1 i don't think that
white is very happy in this position
i mean
tiny bit reduced material already
doesn't seem really bad for
for black are we getting away
yeah
this this this is what
this is what i'm thinking
what to play here bishop c5
um
knight c knight c5
i mean this bit i mean
i
i like this is pretty
if i can play just in my idea here here
here
oh you can take the pawn i will have all
the dark squares but the problem is what
carlton want to play now he wants to
play
knight to d5
and then knight c7 and for the king and
queen
so that's that that's a good idea
and and if white will take black will
take
it's going to take
the phones are shaky at least from
standing standing here
yeah i don't know what to play
you know
now now that i got all the credit before
from f4
for my falsehood so so i have at least
like you know one one card that i can
embarrass myself don't worry there'll be
more in this
evening
somehow
i'm thinking about look d6 and i'll be
honest like i remember a lot a lot a lot
of games i don't actually remember this
so it's not like i have all the analysis
and like i'm looking at it just like you
it's interesting
like i i want to play rook d6
i see that i'm giving this spawn
but i'm thinking
that when you will take this and this
i might be able to invade here and push
those just a thought
i mean don't don't spawn this is
semi sloth lava botvinic variation those
pawns are black's main weapon just an
idea i mean maybe it's a really
bad one but
i see a problem with this one
after take
you might get an extra tempi
taking with the bishop because you're
threatening
your threatening checkmate down
well at least it's an idea
and then play the
bishop c5 that goes to you
mr justin got bishop c5 take take simple
don't need to be smart just play simple
that's good enough
exactly so they say 96 was better okay
we we want to go to this square and he
did it first with exchanging there
he played knight to b3
yeah knight is i mean we need to
understand what's the difference
okay
but talk to d6
knight to f4
knight to f4
pawn take
queen c5
yeah but but you know but but okay but
le
let's say first of all we will look at
that in a second we'll look at 90s 86
first of all let's understand why he
went to b3 he went to b3 because
b3 by white bothered him
so now let's see why the analysis
suggests that it doesn't bother him b3
b4
aha
ah and
okay take this is the problem e2 is
hanging and b4
that's casting white material
and queen of course cannot take because
just the bishop will take on d5 and then
we'll
protect yeah
so now actually i owe you
i owe you look d6
but the hook is defended by the pawn
yeah but but but okay i have several
moves to think i still like knight f4
but all thing is possible but what
happened if i just go here
i mean there are not so many pieces on
the board i can maybe allow myself to
play this move okay i play i play this
you know there's always this magic
button that is called
take back you know that's that's that's
the advantage of uh
analysis
okay play king e7
so
okay i will take
okay beautiful
you know and then we are arguing why you
only went down 100 something points
okay i play king f8 so what
you gave me a check and then what
queen c5
resign beautiful
you know
i'll send i'll send the uscf rating that
that suggests in this line you know
they'll put you know
an active
seriously
like you're you're you're stronger than
that just
tiny bits of thing
i like this move
because if the key doesn't matter i want
to play knight d4 next one
no this this bishop
this bishop is really really really
blocked
what happens if at this point queen b6
for white
julian suggested i just go back
doesn't matter first i can just move the
check the same the same thing
same thing
checked
but but even if you
even if you have check
i go here
checks
checks are pretty but not doing anything
okay
so now why this is less attractive
maybe 95 in the 90s tiny far away i
don't know
well queen b6 yeah knight d5
just
look at that
f4
okay
yes interesting
but what if pawn take
g
i mean
then then danny would like to play queen
b6
i guess this is some heavy stuff
yeah he wants to play queen b6 either
way and okay this this super dangerous
white got
the most important is most important
piece that was doing nothing in the game
this is just some analysis okay
and
yeah
you can hear back back
because the queen the king cannot step
back because of
rook d8
g take
queen h3 yeah i thought maybe here but
wow
maybe if queen b6
take and the rook is attacking the queen
right something something like this
let's look together queen b6
take
oh no but here this is also no yeah but
this
yeah this is killing
oh which is better
oh
worried about it but what's white why
doesn't ever move
okay you're all scaring me thinking that
i completely blundered everything so
which move queen takes i i wanted to
actually what is black's real big threat
here
not to take g2
not bishop thick
dude i started watching
my favor my two favorite tv shows i
started watching today
like this will be the analysis i'm going
back to the chess home and continues
another day
queen check seriously i i give away my
tv shows to come here and that's what
you're giving me
no
queen a7 is is just winning let's say
white just plays
nothing okay like a move that means
nothing here move the knight
this is checkmate
because bishop take and also here this
is crucial line
because the king cannot escape to d2
checkmate so this is actually a real big
threat so
if you take the pawn on e5 it looks
dangerous
but not even taking here but just this
is killing it's just checkmate like
really like winning over there
i mean i mean this is really i mean okay
okay look
computer is minus three whatever okay
that
and minus three exactly minus five so i
wasn't joking here just for you what
happens if knight b1 played
checkmate
no so this is the threat okay beautiful
alrighty
so that's why queen h3 no what but the
queen has to find
somewhere something
okay i'm i'm amazed that they say this
is okay for
this is okay for white
play here here
interesting because the queen on h4 is
amazing
it has those threats when the king is
here it has those threats
this is amazing square for the queen
amazing
and it's protecting f2
in some lines
okay i i would still think why it's bad
black is better but they say this is
super duper complicated
but f4 our idea that we mentioned okay
well
magnus what to do
play queen b6
what now should we run with the king one
for our life
94 right
julian redeemed himself
not yet okay
this night to stop so strong
yeah
but
is he really going to be able to survive
here
probably not this is just a full
exchange down full exchange not even for
a poor not even for anything
so knight d5 98 b5
yeah if 95 just taken bishop back
very good
check
yeah exchanging queen is helpless for
for white
if king f8 queen eight six let's see if
they okay they also mention queen what
happens if queen takes d4
yeah but this end game is not so
actually
now i remember the end game they had
here tiny bit but i really didn't
remember so much
this part
yeah queen b6 exchanging
the king is cut probably it's winning
probably it's winning
okay so basically this will transpose i
assume
okay
yeah
okay interesting
yeah the pawn
is this the actual game
yes
yeah
just let just be clear
this was the position the critical one
and f4 a brilliant idea to give the
queen some squares and open the bishop
diagonal was
seems to be only safe for white yes
yeah
so
i mean can we play something else
okay so let's say you want to play
bishop f1
that's actually a super duper decent
question
what what should black play here
i think i think i have a decent move
here
i hope i i hoped
g4 bishop takes g4
none of those moves we like
probably the number one and two and you
know i'm gonna
feeling like an idiot in a second but
we don't like those ones but there's
something i like
so
once you suggest the move i like we will
see what is right or wrong
and then if julian will be right and i'm
wrong i will not be able to say
anything evil to him the entire night
okay we're not playing let's play every
legal move on the board and see
actually
actually h3 is not bad
but i want something else
but i will just take
we don't give materials for no reason
you know we don't we keep them with our
lives and we only when we know what we
get we give material
yeah you don't
you don't
any any
savior
i will tell you what i think and then we
will see
those spawns
this bishop in this night
they all control one color of squares
all of them control light squares
i want something to control the dark
squares
i want something
my feeling what i would play you know
for whatever right or wrong
i will play this move
i like this move
again i hope i
didn't blunder anything i don't think i
did
take take this is protected and if 92
rook d6
if queen c5
i'll play this
i'm controlling lots of dark squares
here
but it's defended by the knight
so this this i like i like a lot why
don't i like g4
there is not gonna
two reasons one
black is not going to have any checkmate
over there
so you should not play for checkmate
black is we if black without queens
black is winning here the game is over
black has to be careful not to get
killed
for whatever reason one
what is black's most important piece
here which one
the knight
so now let's see what you want to play
you want to play this
okay i want to play this
bishop take pawn okay
i'll take
king f2
the same the same bothers me about this
immediately
i mean maybe there's some ideas there
but it just looks like
okay no this is hanging this is thinking
this really looks
i
mean okay
let's see
what are our thoughts here
yeah
queen d8 queen d6 just winning
no but but but it's just about
understanding black is so weak on the
dark squares
so weak this is weak
this is weak
this is weak
nothing on the dark squares
let me get this queen here i don't need
anything more on light squares
yeah
queen d8
by the way
i i i no i i just yeah
magnus magnus best move obviously
no nothing i mean just white black is
going to play
kingdom now by the way let's see
the brilliancy move g4
i'm still better
okay i'm clear you
you threw away all your advantage after
f4
bishop takes d4
you're lost
lost
right
most important thing is the knight on d4
if the knight can stay on d4 that's it
so they went to this end game
and i remember that anand won it like in
super duper great style but i don't
remember how
yeah g3 okay
h3 maybe bishop f1
yeah okay f6 is logical
a question
would exchanging pawns favor
who
white big time white right
i mean white can exchange all those
and keep the bishop and just make a
simple draw right king and a bishop
simple draw
so that's why taking would be really bad
for black and if f4 for example would be
would be played then
black might black might take this one
so that he will be left with this pawn
over there
rookie two brilliant move
aha preventing
f4
preventing f4
let's see what they say here here here
now the thing is that if those are
exchanged in some versions it can be a
draw
they say this is a theoretical draw we
are not going to start discussing
fortresses but
no
this is so difficult this position
so
if he if he has dreams to play a fall
can he take take an h3 maybe but then
then he weakened okay that's what he
played but then he weakened the dark
squares
end game that we've seen before probably
won't be droish anymore
okay here we go
here we go
the pawn is here
oh this is still complicated endgame
actually because power had a
very similar end game
similar one that he didn't win it was
really complicated to win but okay i
mean
it's
he should have won
yeah they wanted to get the position
with the pawn on h2
honestly we are not going to discuss it
for two reasons one it will not be our
point two
i don't know enough to discuss that
but i do know that this is winning
yeah the important thing is to start to
start
kicking the king away i think like you
will need to check and then king g2 and
push the king i think that's how he's
gonna win this
okay
ah okay this is winning simply wherever
the bishop gonna step
the rook will attack it and then
head to
the back rank so he's kicking he has to
he has to push him
this so now he has a threat already
right what is the threat
taken advance
so bishop goes somewhere bishop c8
always
take it as far as possible
work
back
he has to push the king why does he have
to push the king because then at some
point you can come back and
either
sec well basically sacrifice for example
if white king is here
let's make it as simple as possible and
the book is here
you play here here take the king is not
enough so he has to push it i think
probably pushing to the c file should be
enough all right
all right
wow this is difficult
but he
resigned i guess
look
amazing
because he's gonna if king hill is just
gonna take
and if bishop goes
he's pushed him to the c file no but
this it looks so simple but when the
world champion is doing it it looks so
simple
so now he's cut on the c file
that's enough
yeah that that's what you need to do i
mean those things look so simple but
you have to push the king
all the way so this is one of the best
well actually it's a great great game by
anand the theorem
you